[Aplausos]
[Música]
en manual macrón parece el político
perfecto para caerle bien a todo el
mundo es lo suficientemente progre como
para enamorar a los actores de hollywood
y lo suficientemente liberal como para
seducir a los tiburones de wall street-
fuera de francia todo el mundo quiere
hacerse un self y con makram ahora bien
dentro de francia es una historia
totalmente distinta atentos el fuego
estalla en parís mientras la huelga
general crea una pesadilla al turismo
cerrando la torre eiffel y las
estaciones de metro esta noticia es de
varias semanas antes de que la pandemia
del sars coronavirus 2 copar a todos los
medios de comunicación y en principio
pocos os vais a sorprender las revueltas
violentas son algo tan típico en francia
como el cross and o los menas atrás pero
la pregunta es por qué protestan esta
vez pues nada más y nada menos que por
la reforma de las pensiones
[Música]
vamos a decirlo claro tanto francia como
españa como muchos otros países tienen
un problema muy serio con el sistema de
pensiones ambos países france y españa
tiene un sistema de reparto donde los
trabajadores pagan las pensiones de los
jubilados cada vez hay menos gente joven
cotizando y más gente mayor cobrando
conclusión el sistema está al borde del
colapso y veréis las pensiones tienen
algo en común con la pandemia del
coronavirus en ambos casos se trata de
un problema grave un problema que puede
colapsar el país entero el colapso de
las pensiones no es un problema
cualquiera es el problema tanto en
francia como en españa pero muy pocos
políticos quieren hablar de esto
seriamente porque pues porque todas las
soluciones pasan por medidas impopulares
de igual modo que ningún político quería
obligar a sus ciudadanos a confinarse
ningún político quiere decir que no hay
más dinero para las pensiones
[Música]
y creedme las pensiones en francia
necesitan una reforma para que os hagáis
una idea hablamos de las pensiones más
generosas del mundo los jubilados
franceses reciben de media a un 61 por
ciento de su último sueldo cuando en
alemania sólo reciben el 38 por ciento
de hecho la media de la ocde es del 49
por ciento además la edad de jubilación
de francia para recibir la pensión sin
penalización está fijada en los 62 años
por comparar mientras que en españa está
en los 65 camino ya situarse en los 67
que fijo el anterior gobierno socialista
y lo cierto es que 67 años ya es la edad
de retiro en alemania y ya sé lo que
pensáis muchos entonces macrón quiere
bajar las pensiones y subir la edad de
jubilación pues nada de eso la reforma
de las pensiones de macrón no llega tan
lejos y toca la edad de jubilación ni
toca las pensiones así que la pregunta
es cuál es el problema entonces porque
esta reforma de las pensiones es tan
controvertida y lo que es más importante
servir a la reforma de macrón para
abordar el problema de las pensiones en
europa hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
[Música]
vestigios del rey sol
en los últimos 400 años francia ha
pasado del rey sol es decir del
absolutismo más absoluto a tener una de
las democracias más sólidas del mundo
sin embargo hay algo que no se suele
mencionar el rey absoluto de francia no
era la única persona con privilegios
detrás suyo había toda una corte de
nobles funcionarios y trabajadores que
también vivían mucho mejor que el pueblo
llano entonces es cuando llegó la
revolución francesa el pueblo se hizo
con el poder bajo el lema de libertad
igualdad y fraternidad y aquí viene la
parte que tampoco sale en los libros de
historia si es cierto los
revolucionarios cortaron la cabeza del
rey y de tantos otros ahora bien no se
puede construir un nuevo país matando a
todas las élites que lo gobernaban antes
así que pasaba la revolución pero hubo
élites hubo colectivos que lograron
conservar sus privilegios y no sólo por
unos años os hablo de privilegios que
llegan hasta nuestros días y está por
ejemplo el cuerpo de bailarines y
trabajadores de la ópera de parís que
gozan de un régimen especial para su
jubilación desde mil 698
habéis oído bien mil 698 y por ese
motivo podemos encontrarnos noticias
como esta la ópera de parís en huelga
para defender las pensiones de louis 14
y diréis qué privilegio otorgó el rey
sol a los bailarines pues ni más ni
menos que jubilarse a los 42 años que sí
que ya no sé que la danza es un arte muy
duro y que lleva el cuerpo humano al
extremo vale pero dos cosas quiero
deciros yo una es que la medicina ha
avanzado un poquito en los últimos años
y digo yo que algo podrá aliviar la
medicina moderna a los bailarines de hoy
en día pero hay una segunda cosa y es
que los trabajadores de la ópera de niza
o de burdeos no pueden acogerse a este
régimen especial de jubilación porque
pues porque esto sólo beneficia a los
sucesores de los bailarines que hace 400
años tuvieron la suerte de entretener al
rey sol es decir los que trabajan en la
ópera de parís en otras palabras que no
se puede discutir es un privilegio del
libro un privilegio que viene de antes
incluso de la revolución francesa pero
esperad un momento porque estos no son
los únicos privilegiados
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en la sociedad francesa de ferrocarriles
es la empresa estatal que explota el
sector ferroviario en régimen de
monopolio sus trabajadores están
considerados como los más privilegiados
de francia se pueden jubilar con dos
tercios de su salario a los 50 años al
acogerse a un régimen especial que viene
cuando los maquinistas tenían que a
palear carbón aunque su edad de
jubilación se elevará hasta los 52 años
en 2024 los trabajadores de esta empresa
seguirán trabajando una década menos que
el resto de trabajadores franceses pero
en el fondo esto tampoco es algo que
debiera extrañarnos al fin y al cabo hay
hasta 42 regímenes especiales diferentes
para acceder a la jubilación en francia
como podéis ver conceder privilegios va
con el adn francés lo mismo da en
democracia que con monarcas absolutos o
emperadores también les pasó a mediados
del siglo 20 cuando se estableció el
estado del bienestar como siempre os
decimos aquí en visual político el
[ __ ] está en los detalles el problema
no es el estado del bienestar en sí
mismo sino qué tipo de estado del
bienestar queremos tener uno elitista
no igualitario
[Música]
por ejemplo el estado del bienestar en
países nórdicos como suecia es muy
generoso con cualquiera que ostente la
ciudadanía del país sin embargo sus
funcionarios no tienen privilegios
especiales como si tienen en otros
países europeos son considerados como
clase media y por tanto no se considera
oportuno que deban tener ningún tipo de
privilegio todo esto tiene lógica si
tenemos en cuenta quiénes son los padres
del estado del bienestar sueco los
socialdemócratas suecos que venían de la
clase obrera por eso no querían que los
funcionarios que mayoritariamente venían
de la clase media tuvieran ningún tipo
de privilegio
[Aplausos]
pero francia no es suecia hablamos de un
país muy elitista para que os hagáis una
idea casi todos los líderes políticos de
este país vienen de la misma universidad
la escuela nacional de administración se
trata de una escuela donde los hijos de
las élites se forman para ser políticos
en la última promoción sólo un 1 por
ciento de los estudiantes venía de una
familia humilde dicho de otra forma que
por raro que suene el país de la liberté
égalité y fraternité tiene el elitismo
grabado en el adn podríamos decir que
francia vive una revolución permanente
de republicanos que en el fondo quieren
ser emperadores así que hablamos de un
estado del bienestar con privilegios ahí
están por ejemplo los funcionarios de
carrera que tienen su puesto de trabajo
garantizado en la administración pública
además a diferencia de suecia donde
cobran menos en francia un funcionario
cobra prácticamente igual que si
trabajara para la empresa privada
pero esa es la jubilación donde más
salen a relucir todos estos privilegios
de los funcionarios franceses mientras
que en la empresa privada se tiene en
cuenta el sueldo de los últimos 25 años
para calcular la pensión de los
funcionarios solamente se les mira sus
últimos seis años
y claro imaginad todos los complementos
que cobran en sus últimos años por
ejemplo imaginad a una persona que
empiece su carrera como consultor júnior
y llega a ser socio de la empresa es muy
posible que su pensión sea más reducida
que la de cualquier funcionario cuando
se calcula la media de sus últimos 25
años laborales y os preguntaréis pero
cuál es el problema de todo esto cuál es
el problema de que haya unos colectivos
con mejores condiciones de jubilación
que el resto pues el problema es que
cuando alguien quiere meter mano por
aquí estos grupos concretos se levantan
en armas es lo más lógico imaginad que
el gobierno nos diera a los youtubers
dos mil euros al mes por nuestra cara
bonita pues y dentro de 30 años algún
canalla se propone retirarnos este
privilegio
muchos no se preguntarán si eso es justo
o no simplemente saldrán a la calle y
protestarán es más probablemente yo
sería el primero
[Música]
todo esto explica que en francia cada
vez que un político ha querido reformar
las pensiones la calle se le ha echado
encima jacques chirac quiso acabar en
sus inicios con los regímenes especiales
pero fracasó las protestas sindicales de
1995 son míticas luego sarkozy y yolanda
impulsaron algunos cambios pero no se
atrevieron a meter mano a estos
colectivos privilegiados aún así de
derechas o socialistas ambos gobiernos
fueron presionados por la movilización
sindical sin embargo lo que estos
presidentes tuvieron enfrente no es nada
comparado con lo de ahora graves
altercados la policía cargando contra
los manifestantes y pensaréis pero qué
pasa con la reforma de macrón que ha
hecho para provocar unas protestas más
fuertes que las de 1995 pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
[Música]
la reforma de macrón
a estas alturas os preguntaréis cuál es
el principal cambio que propone macrón
pues ni más ni menos que acabar con los
42 regímenes especiales de jubilación el
sistema actual es deficitario y no está
para aguantar privilegios a cambio
macrón presenta un sistema universal de
puntos en el que todos los trabajadores
reciban puntos por su cotización y no
importe en qué sector hayas trabajado
estos puntos valdrán exactamente lo
mismo para los bailarines o los
maquinistas los funcionarios o los
youtubers así que claro aunque los
sindicatos desconocían cómo sería la
reforma y los trabajadores ignoraban
cómo les afectaría las protestas contra
el gobierno comenzaron incluso antes de
que se presentara la dichosa reforma
porque pues porque todos los
privilegiados ya sabían que el chollo se
les iba a terminar
también hay otro factor que no podemos
ignorar con macrón y con su partido la
república en marcha y es que tanto la
izquierda como la derecha necesitan
hacer sangre con macros porque la
situación es la siguiente tras el
gobierno del socialista françois
hollande que aprobó importantes recortes
la clase trabajadora buscó respuestas en
otras fuerzas políticas por tanto la
movilización contra la reforma de las
pensiones ha propiciado el momento para
que la izquierda reclame su protagonismo
en la calle frente a otros movimientos
que escapan de su control como el de los
chalecos amarillos así que este debate
se ha convertido en una oportunidad
buenísima para los sindicatos que
reivindican que son los que defienden al
pueblo contra el gobierno pero también
ha sido una oportunidad perfecta para la
extrema derecha no se debe retener nada
en este sistema de pensiones propuesto
por el gobierno quiero decir que todo se
debe tirar a la basura en la época de
chirac o sarkozy todo estaba muy claro
quien protestaba los sindicatos de
izquierda pero la política francesa de
hoy en día es mucho más complicada que
todo esto tanto la extrema izquierda
como la extrema derecha están de acuerdo
en una
ambos odian a macramé así que mientras
macrón tiene la mejor imagen fuera de
francia dentro es todo lo contrario para
la izquierda es un malvado capitalista
contra los derechos laborales para la
derecha es un progre que quiere acabar
con unos privilegios tan interiorizados
como la identidad nacional y en que se
traduce todo esto pues en estas
protestas multitudinarias y diréis cómo
ha reaccionado macrón ante esta
respuesta callejera pues lo cierto es
que su primer movimiento ha sido muy
convencional para ser un representante
de la nueva política seis mil gendarmes
para reprimir a los sindicatos y claro
si le sumas el precedente de los
chalecos amarillos hay veces que el
asunto se le ha ido al gobierno de las
manos la cron denuncia la violencia
policial y exige un código de ética
mejorado las pensiones suponen un gasto
del 14 por ciento del pib para francia
en la ocde la media es del 8% ya en las
elecciones que le llevaron al palacio
presidencial del elíseo macrón prometió
que haría una reforma de las pensiones y
al que su planteamiento era ambicioso
macrón ha ido suavizando sus medidas por
ejemplo ahora
de forma ya no afectará a los mayores de
45 años sin embargo tampoco se aplicará
a los maquinistas mayores de 35 años ni
a los bailarines de la ópera de parís
que sólo les afectará a los que empiezan
a trabajar allí en el año 2022 pero la
mayor concesión encierra un golpe
político akrón quería subir a los 64
años la edad para jubilarse con la
pensión completa sin penalización alguna
el objetivo era incentivar que la gente
se retire más tarde y atajar el déficit
del sistema que podría alcanzar los 12
mil millones de euros sin embargo el
gobierno anunció que renunciaba a los 64
años a cambio de pasarles a otros la
patata caliente reforma de las pensiones
los sindicatos y la patronal tienen tres
meses para encontrar un equilibrio
financiero para 2027 sin embargo todas
estas discusiones se frenaron en seco
con la llegada de la pandemia tanto la
patronal como los sindicatos acordaron
con el gobierno dejar este tema hasta el
año en el que estamos ahora mismo 2021
es decir que es justo ahora cuando
francia espera retomar este debate y la
situación política ha cambiado
ligeramente curiosamente los porcentajes
de aprobación
y han crecido con el coronavirus ahora
mismo con un 40 por ciento de aprobación
macrón es el presidente más popular de
francia en 20 años de hecho podría ser
el primer presidente que repite mandato
en este siglo ahora bien por mucha
aprobación que tenga las encuestas de
intención de voto no son tan favorables
en el momento en el que hacemos este
vídeo hay muchos sondeos en los que
manuel macrón empata con marine lepén de
momento su proyecto de ley ya ha llegado
al senado y se ha encontrado con 41 mil
enmiendas casi nada pero no importa
macará no tiene la mayoría suficiente
como para aprobar la reforma de las
pensiones en los términos que considere
adecuados
la pregunta es para vosotros queréis que
macro cns se atreverá a sacar su reforma
de las pensiones aprovechando las buenas
encuestas y su mayoría en las cámaras
legislativas hasta qué punto esto le
puede pasar factura en las próximas
elecciones del año que viene
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual político sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]